yeah a dark house prank etiquette hell
out there at kells linear brothers loss
right there Ellie did you hear me know
what look hospital this is where we get
off let's go kiddo and a madea zombie in
a while feel that breeze huh I'll tell
you on a day like this I just sit on my
porch put the way my sex ring all right
let's go over this whole thing they
teach you how to play guitar era I
reckon you'd really like that are you
say they're gonna die I'm not getting
out Dinah hey I'm talking to you huh oh
yeah sure that sounds great let's have a
hair hello lady hey you know I ready to
this stuff but it's like carrots like
that I beg hottie palace hey ok ok ok
I'll pretty Oh God God a chef
I dreamt about flying the other night oh
yeah yeah i just got walking what's
gonna happen was a stupid dream now tell
me about it all right there i got okay
where are the enemies all right kind of
weight look at that another city another
abandoned quarantine zone that on here
there's that Hospital the Firefly
mention come on kiddo let's go baby I
say it's just me a real ones i drop it
in maybe we cut through here huh hey bae
of course way well where's the [ __ ] I
gotta drag thank you out to wife um read
it
we never clue back then I didn't have a
club etch okay oh that's a [ __ ] with me
huh want to make my eyes I catch it here
take a crazy battle or some [ __ ] the
heck ok I have to get up there I was
probably a lot or so much what is that I
pick up any of these where's the ladder
I know there's one here yeah you don't
need to hide it for me ladder ladder
anyone have a ladder here looking for a
ladder ladder that's enough sin here
just [ __ ] out all day is what it is I
have my hem take me after and I have a
drug gang like what's up with you did
everything alright yeah I'm fine yeah
you just kind of seemed extra quiet
today oh sorry no it's not
it's ryan is it that like is that good
fine let it go through there I don't see
how thou [ __ ] is going on here it's
gonna get out later okay i guess i just
bought a lot of myself hi turns out here
otters anyone find a lot are they don't
made [ __ ] in here [ __ ] hey get up here
oh right there no we could use that
ladder yes uh I to believe that Elena
you help me go early
early disinfect their bladder hey I got
over here can I just shot her you kind
of [ __ ] up on it oh my god le le
that's [ __ ] great you gotta see this
what is it
I'll say anything the hills
hey are you kidding me
but
but is it
uh what do I like it at
mon hurry up
the [ __ ] is that
Oh always set
come here oh [ __ ] is right here
oh my god it's effective
where's it off to your come on let's go
say slow down kiddo
I just let me [ __ ] I can't comment wait
while gonna
Oh
two
is everything you were hoping for it's
got its ups and downs but he can't deny
the view though uh-huh
pretty cool
it's really nice where are they Colorado
ok so it's next on the horizon
what's that we don't have to do this you
know that right what's the other option
go back to tommy's just they done with
this whole damn thing hmm after all
we've been through everything that I've
done murder liked why of evil it can't
be for nothing
like a belter oh look I know you mean
well but there's no halfway with this
once we're done we'll go wherever you
want okay well I'm leaving without you
let's go wrap this up hey how is this
give me that [ __ ] hey what game makes
you feel like a [ __ ] Iraq count okay
this place takes me back ha so I was
right after everything went down I ended
up in a triage just like this everywhere
you looked just south families torn
apart yes whole damn world seemed diff
turned upside down and now for one
yes I can't imagine losing something
love like that losing everything that
you know I lost my schedule I pay say
it's okay
hey where we go where's the hospital and
everything I got something for you
here Maria showed this to me and I uh I
stole it I hope you don't mind
I don't no matter how hard you try I
guess you can't escape your past thank
you okay what's over here oh that's
gonna happen now where's the hospital
which way a [ __ ] guy oh it's alec
city ditch out for Harambee